joining us now long time general manager
of the minnesota vikings straight from
his office at the teams facility an
excellent and beautiful facility by the
way i was there a couple of years ago
right after it opened he's rick spielman
rick welcome back how are you pal hey
mike thanks for having me on today great
to talk to you and i've been looking
forward to asking you this question
contents of the first communication
between you
and your brother chris
when he took a job with the lions
uh he asked how my mother was doing and
so i filled him in on that and uh i got
up on a lot of uh family things but uh
nothing business related but uh no i was
very excited for him i know it's a great
opportunity for him just to be involved
and you know detroit is home for him
that's where they drafted that's where
he was drafted and and felt that uh if
he can
somehow get in there in whatever
capacity help and be an assistant to the
owner and you know the
head coach in the gm will make all the
calls in there but any way he can assist
i know he's looking forward to doing
that
well it has to change things though from
the perspective of how willing you'll be
to bounce ideas off of him you're going
to be more guarded he's going to be
guarded that's got to be the dynamic now
you're you're both working for enemy
teams in the same division
yeah well
well it'll be interesting uh it was fun
when we played him in the last game this
year although he just got up there just
to see him
um but
you know we've always even when he was a
broadcaster we never crossed the line on
what he had to do from an integrity
standpoint or me giving him any insider
information that i wouldn't give
anything else so
um we understand where that line is from
the business side of it but he is also
my brother probably my closest friend in
the world
and uh we you know i talk to him almost
on a daily or every other day basis
have you at least asked him to tell his
new head coach dan campbell to inform
the players that they should not
actually bite the kneecaps off of viking
players they can bite all the other
kneecaps they want but not vikings
well my wife i came home and saw and my
wife watched dan campbell's press
conference and she said if i had to pick
a head coach that your brother was
involved with bringing to the detroit
lions that would be the guy
yeah i mean it basically is chris as a
head coach you know the old school
mindset that that in many ways is not
part of football but still is integral
to a team being successful one thing i
want to ask you about you mentioned the
season-ending game against the lions
that game included a very controversial
call of roughing the passer that
extended a vikings drive allowed a
touchdown to be scored
yesterday nfl media reported that
roughing the passer could be subject to
replay review
any preliminary thoughts from you as to
whether or not it's a good idea to put
that play calls and non-calls of
roughing the passer in the bucket of
what's reviewable yeah i know the
competition committee is now putting all
these rules and proposals together i
know
usually we'll meet with the nfl they
give us some statistical analysis on how
many actual
controversial calls
were in the nfl last year and roughing a
passer but there'll be a lot more other
things to discuss too on some potential
rule changes and it's the process every
year so
you know also uh there's going to be
we're going to have to look at a lot of
the potential role changes from what we
were able to do with covet this year you
know on the flexibility of the ir and
being able to bring guys up and down
that way you know the size of the
practice squad so a lot of those are in
discussions right now
and i know those will probably be up at
the time when the owner meetings come up
here at the end of march and it'll be
interesting to see what we learned from
this year's covert rules
uh and any other changes and how it's it
can make the game or make us better at
the jobs that we have to do
especially from a roster planning
standpoint and what actually does move
forward
you know i'm a big fan of replay review
for things that are objectively
identifiable did a guy get two feet and
bounds before he went out of bounds
after catching a pass was the ball out
before the knee was down i get nervous
about it when judgment is involved and
we saw what happened with pass
interference a couple of years ago what
would concern me about roughing the
passers the idea that you're going to go
back and break it down frame by frame
there's 10 different ways that you can
rough the passer you see one little
flash of something that technically
violates the rules and all of a sudden
now comes a flag for roughing the
password when it really wasn't roughing
the passer well hopefully you're you
know you don't know the angles you're
getting to and i think some of that
in the opi and dpi rule we had a couple
years ago that made reviewable sometimes
you don't have all those camera angles
like you do for a national tv game
so
you have to make sure that you have it
covered by all all the camera angles too
if you're going to do something like
that you know i thought you last night
when i saw that one of the other
potential proposals is a reversion to
sudden death overtime obviously that's
the change that was made after the 2009
nfc championship
short field couple of first downs couple
of questionable calls next thing you
know garrett hartley kicks a makeable
field goal and the saints advance and
the vikings don't get a chance to match
it but then i saw what the gist of this
new sudden death is with the spot and
choose dynamic that the ravens are
proposing i don't know how much of a
chance you've had to study it and review
it but i'll tell you what it's one of
those things where
my first thought is what the heck is
this
and then when it's explained
it's a it's a lot more fair than relying
upon which way a coin strikes the turf
yeah no we you know the first time i saw
a lot of these uh new rule proposals was
yesterday in one of our committee
meetings
and so i think the more we delve into
this uh i know the competition committee
i know there's a subcommittee of coaches
uh that are heavily involved in the rule
changes as well so
i think the more we take a deep dive
into this and i do believe you have to
look at from an analytical standpoint
too um what is the potential outcomes if
you do make these rule changes and
are they permanent or are they just on a
one-year basis to see so
i think there'll be a lot of discussions
because there's always two
positives and negatives for each rule
proposal but it'll be interesting to
hear all the different ideas
on on these new rule proposals and if
they'll move forward or not
different scouting process this year
like last year with some
new changes the idea that you can
actually go to pro days this year they
were shut down in 2020 i heard you
mentioned that yesterday in your press
conference how many pro days do you plan
to go to i'm trying to get to 10 to 15
if i can um it's totally different last
year at this time we were able to have a
combine uh got a lot of our work done
there saw a lot of the players work out
at the combine we were also able to see
them play in the fall as well so when
they shut down the pro day visits last
year
uh it probably you always want to get
out there to do that but you you had a
lot of information already
this year i think most of the gm's but i
know myself you know i never was able to
go out and see a college game this year
because of the testing protocol and
traveling with the team and being in the
bubble
um the senior bowl was probably the most
valuable thing we've had so far this off
season to go down there and jim nagy did
an outstanding job on putting that on we
were able to do i believe we counted 128
player interviews in person now we had
mask on we had plexiglass between us but
you actually got to do that in person
instead of virtual and
you know those things are important too
because a lot of things you may not see
uh virtually you can actually see body
language and things like that get a real
good feel for the person and their
personality and then just to get to see
some of these kids
that opted out in 2020 or their schools
didn't play till this spring to see a
couple of those guys go down there and
participate uh was huge for us but this
year the pro days are going to i think
be bigger than ever because of the
limitations we've had and the exposure
we've had to a lot of these uh upcoming
draft prospects so i'm excited to to
really get out out on the road and like
most of my counterparts are i'm sure uh
to see these guys see them move around
and watch them work out for the guys who
walk out or for the guys who played for
the teams that maybe didn't
play in a lot of games last season
um
how hard is it to go back to your 2019
film
and project from that it's got to be
frustrating because you want to have
apples to apples
you you don't have the full set of film
that you ordinarily would have for a lot
of these guys no and we did we knew that
there was going to be restrictions this
year so our uh jamal stevenson our
college director and a lot of our scouts
uh did a lot on all 19 tape on these
guys because we didn't even know if
there was going to be a season in 20 for
a lot of these
schools and especially the power 5 but
then the power 5
came back alive and they did have a uh
they did have a season but then you know
you're watching the kid play in 19 and
why didn't he play as good in 2020 i
don't you know the dynamics on were they
able to work out at school weren't they
able to work out at school what were
they dealing with covet you know so
there's so many
variables that you see some of these
kids that played in 19 said wow he
didn't play very good in 20. but then he
saw a couple kids that popped up and
said yeah he he took another step
forward in 20. so
evaluating this year is really going to
be a a two-year pitcher of what you're
seeing in 19 and what you're seeing in
20 and then you're going to have to kind
of blend that together and come up with
uh what you think that player is you
mentioned yesterday
virtual interviews per player
is that is that unlimited number of
players and what's the time limit for
each of the five interviews you can do
yeah you're allowed up to five you're
allowed one hour per interview um you
know we've had we already started like
most teams have i sat on two or three
yesterday
um just to listen in as as the coaches
talk to the kids um
we uh
it'll be uh you're allowed to have an
unlimited amount of interviews i mean up
to five per player that's it but
unlimited amount of players that you can
interview you can interview 5 000 if you
want to
but strategically we have a plan in
place on who we want to interview
like i said there was a big uh big help
going down to the senior bowl and
knocking out 128 interviews so now the
coaches can piggyback off that but uh
and the other thing is i know you know
during these pro days there's going to
be no private workouts no dinners no
things like that you're at the school
you're doing the work uh you're
following the rules of the university as
far as the covet protocol the state and
local government protocol the nfl
protocol but at least we're out there
and able to get uh get our hands and and
not so much our hands on these guys i
shouldn't say that but just get out
there and see them in person no matter
how much you're able to do anything
always crap shoot first round's a crap
shoot the vikings have seen over the
years at the receiver position one good
one bad one good one badge you hit a
grand slam home run with justin
jefferson last year when did you first
know he was going to be special
you know i i saw him in 19 and he took a
significant jump in 20 and then the
question was was he just going to be a
slot or can you play outside
i think as we went through the process
uh you know saw him down at the combine
didn't get a chance to go to see him in
a workout at all but what really stuck
out
uh when we actually did start in
training camp was that he is such a
unique route runner for a size his
ability to drop his weight to get it out
of cuts and if you watch some of the
highlights
he does get dbs back on their heels and
he can turn them
but also his catching radius and his
courage coming across not afraid to take
a hit
and his run after catch and the one
thing that really stuck out to us last
year was the bigger the games got
towards the end of the season
the better he played and he rose to the
occasion and wanted the ball in those
critical situations those on that big
stage
how nervous were you back in april of
last year as the the picks are coming
off the board and it's creeping down
toward you and is somebody going to take
jefferson or trade in front of you to
get jefferson what was the anxiety level
in those moments well i think everybody
has anxiety on draft day because it's
the unknown i i equated it a little bit
when i talked to the media yesterday on
us sitting there uh waiting for adrian
peterson to fall to us
and you you never know um do you do you
trade up or do you not trade up do you
sit there and and a lot of it could be
just luck of the draw too that he felt
to us
you know but we also prepared that if we
didn't get him what was going to be our
plan b and how we were going to proceed
from there
but we were very excited and very
fortunate that he fell to us and
i think we landed on a pretty good
player
you made it clear yesterday that kirk
cousins is the guy for this year he's
got two years left on his current
contract salary of 35 million becomes
fully guaranteed on march 19 salary for
next year of 35 million fully guaranteed
would you like to extend tweak do
something with his contract sooner
rather than later yeah we're not going
to talk i don't want to talk about any
of the business that we're doing you
know in general terms i know we have
some challenges facing us just like most
teams do with the cap going down
a lot of the contracts that we did were
pre pandemic in trying to project where
the cap was going to go up uh the delta
went the other way there was a pretty
significant delta so
we're trying to figure out right now
on how we are able to get underneath the
cap but also get enough room so we can
improve our team
and i think whether that's through free
agency in the draft we got to get some
help on the defensive side of the ball
and the offense was rolling pretty good
yes last year
but getting a deal hunter back getting a
mike pierce back and anthony barr back
but we also got a lot of work to do from
a contractual standpoint on more than
one player and there's a fascinating
dynamic rick that i think can unfold as
teams look at their rosters and decide
that
it's not in their best cap interest to
keep a certain player and more players
become available
then you have other options with guys
who
aren't currently on your team i mean how
willing and active are you going to be
in after you get through the wave of
getting under the cap
you see guys out there who may be dollar
for dollar or better value than guys
that are still on the roster are you
going to be willing in those moments to
say
hey i can get
best interest of the team i can get
somebody out here who's going to take a
contract i evaluate evaluated skills i
say it's a better value than a guy i
have are we going to see that happen and
are you going to be inclined to
constantly take a look back at your own
roster and ask is there somebody else
out there
that better fits at a better price what
we're trying to do yeah that's our job
um that's what we do and that's what uh
you know you're trying to do
pretty much 24 7 is improve your roster
the dynamic will be interesting on how
many teams do cut players uh and the
value of that player the type of player
that's going to come out on the open
market just seeing a couple of players
already
that have been cut
but then you're going to weigh in how's
that going to affect potentially the
free agent market you know because if
you have guys
out there that have been cut and you go
that direction instead of maybe an
unrestricted free agent that doesn't
affect your compensatory picks uh down
down down the road
also it'll be interesting i think the
top guys will still get paid
because there are teams out there with
cap
but it'll be interesting to see once
that first wave goes through and
if there is
a lot of veterans out there that have
been cut
uh just because of the cap situation we
are in right now
uh
the scrambling teams are going to do to
identify those guys and try to add them
to the roster i mean when a j.j watt
gets out there there's a lot of teams
definitely from which you read off of
pro football talk
that there were a lot of teams that were
very interested in them but if there are
a lot of caliber players like that out
there it may be a whole different market
than we've ever seen before i think the
reality that there's going to be a
middle class of guys to get squeezed and
they have to just pick a one-year deal
and there could just be a rash of good
players recognizable names one year
contract joining whichever team they can
find a spot with where they think
there's a fit where they think they can
contend
and
that could be
a powerful tool in building a team for
this year and that's our job it's it's
we have to every year every team's
trying to improve their roster to fill
their needs and
what becomes available that's your job
to be as aggressive as you can
to go out there and get the best players
possible to give you a chance to win
this is gonna be the fourth offensive
coordinator for kirk cousins in his time
with the vikings
i think it's six now six three years
well and it it's amazing how that that
door spins but do you see this as as not
really a change because it's the same
system it's just one kubiak
passing the torch to another kubiak
i i think uh and i i'll defer to coach
zim and the coach
clint kubiak on any of the changes that
they're going to make from a schematic
standpoint but i know coach zim loves
the system we run i know it fits the
quarterback very well we've built
uh the offense around this system
and the more continuity you have the
more chance of success that you have as
long as you knock on wood stay healthy
uh but i think the you know kirk's been
almost you know kevin stefanski had a
little bit of this system in place when
uh coach when gary came in and was kind
of like the uh senior offensive
assistant uh an assistant head coach so
this will be the third year clint's
actually going to be in this system that
we're running right now
you know we're about the same age i grew
up in the 70s i discovered football in
72 with the immaculate reception game
between the steelers and the raiders
in the course of that next 12 months i
became a vikings fan when i was eight
years old and i remember super bowl
eight vividly i remember super bowl nine
vividly the playoff game in 75 when drew
pearson pushed off and it wasn't called
vividly super bowl in 76 vividly and
every playoff loss after that there are
plenty of vikings fans out there and i'm
i consider myself a partially reformed
vikings fan but i know that they just
want one super bowl win
in their lifetimes
what's your message to the folks who
have been waiting whether it's 10 20 30
40 50 years or longer who are saying
just one trophy in our lifetimes i i
don't think you're in this business
unless you want to win that trophy and i
know
with our ownership group and the will
family and all the resources they give
us not only from us bank stadium but tco
performance center
uh to the resources to go out and buy
the best i would say buy but the
resources to go out and do contracts on
the best players we can get
you know we walk into this building
every day and
the number one goal is to how do we get
to win a super bowl and whether that's
improving on the coaching side as far
schematically
improving on the personnel side to me if
you're if you don't walk into your
building every day and that's your
number one goal then you're in the wrong
business and our goal and objective
every year is to come in here and try to
win a super bowl what would you say to
the vikings fans who look at the team
over the past 20 years and say
hey
the vikings contend every year they're
in the playoff mix every year they get
to the playoffs every other year or
thereabouts
good team but it always seems like
there's some other team every year that
has gone fully all in creates a dominant
team
and the vikings
eventually walk into that buzz saw in a
playoff year
how do you strike that balance between
building a team that contends
on a regular basis
versus
let's go for the brass ring right now
even if it screws us up one two three
years down the road
if you go
what you're talking about kind of an
all-in approach
the one thing you can't predict is what
happens from an injury standpoint
every year
your goal i mean is it like everybody
has the same goal but if you can get
into the playoffs every year
it gives you a chance to have a chance
if you happen to get hot that year
or the you know this play happens or
that play happens it keeps you going
forward
uh and then it just clicks on that one
year i mean we got close couple years
ago when case keenan was our third
quarterback that came in here and got us
to the championship game and we just
you know didn't get it over the hump in
philly that night but every year you
just want to give yourself a chance
in the playoffs and then when it clicks
and i use philly as a great example they
lost once that year
and foles came in and was kind of
struggling early but all sudden he got
hot at the right time
and played his lights out
which ended up beating new england up
here in the super bowl so as long as you
can give yourself a chance to get in the
playoffs
and then let's see what happens from
there
last one for you and this just occurred
to me while we were talking we've spent
a lot of time in the media assessing the
impact of tom brady's jump from new
england to tampa bay on other
quarterbacks who look at
at his situation what he did and maybe
emboldening them to make similar moves
from a team perspective from your
perspective when you look at what the
buccaneers were able to do
in one year
what what lessons do you take away from
that that you're comfortable sharing to
an audience are there lessons to be
learned
by your teams from that
everybody has their own different
philosophies on how they're going to
build a team and and jason lake did a
phenomenal job down there and
you know uh even though i cannot speak
of other players on other rosters tom
brady is maybe the best quarterback that
ever played in the game of
football but i also know that they did a
heck of a job building a team around tom
brady too so it wasn't on his shoulders
they had a they had a good defense they
had playmakers on offense so they had a
good team and they were
just like everything it's such a
marathon every nfl season and at some
point people were wondering whether they
were going to get in the playoffs or not
and all of a sudden something changed
when they came out by week and got on a
roll
and you hit that bus saw
and so those are the things and it's not
like they had a
a bye week the first week of the
playoffs and they had to go on the road
and had a win in green bay which was a
tough environment to go up there and win
and playing against aaron rodgers and
the stars just aligned and they and like
i said jason and them did a great job
putting that roster together and in a
click form this year and they were able
to accomplish the goal that they set out
and that's a great point rick no matter
how much work you put in this time of
year or preseason training camp regular
season it always seems like
it is for one team an alignment of the
planets in a special way and it just
works and you just want to be in
position that maybe
this year next year whatever year the
planets line up for you we'll we'll let
you get back to work on getting the
planets to line up for the vikings this
year next year whenever great work last
year and getting justin jefferson
congratulations on all your success with
the vikings we look forward to talking
to you again real soon
thanks i appreciate you having me on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports